esta tarjeta nos va a permitir
distribuir la energía a diferentes
componentes de manera que tengamos
nuestra terminal positiva y negativa y
los conectamos aquí y todo lo demás que
necesite 5 voltios de energía lo
conectaremos aquí y podrá recibir esta
energía ya que cuando conectamos un
positivo aquí y un negativo acá vamos a
proporcionar energía a todos estos
puntos de conexión a diferencia de este
circuito provisional que parece una
galleta y del que hablamos en un vídeo
previo aquí si ponemos energía en un
punto esto va a dar energía a todo este
renglón pero solo al renglón en el que
está conectado aquí vemos estas tiras
estos clips que conducen la energía a
todo lo largo vamos a recortar nuestra
tira de energía que es parte de nuestro
circuito provisional y vamos a
recortarlo hasta aquí para que podamos
colocarlo frente al arduino
colocarlo en esta superficie al cortar
esto deben sostenerlo del otro lado ya
que las tiras de metal que están adentro
podrían salirse al estar cortando hacia
abajo y queremos asegurarnos de
cortarlos también ahora vamos a limar
esta parte para suavizar los bordes
usamos una lima estándar para esto
muy bien ya tenemos nuestra pieza con
tres secciones en ella esto va a
distribuir nuestra energía veamos que
tal queda
aquí tenemos que cuidar el espacio así
que usamos cinta de doble cara en la
parte de atrás de esto y la pegaremos en
la base pero antes volvemos a checar que
quepa bien 'nuestro arduino por encima
de esto
ahora si ponemos esto en su lugar aunque
debemos asegurarnos nuevamente de que
todo quepa bien antes de apretar con
fuerza y dejar esto bien pegado ponemos
el arduino y vemos que tenemos que mover
esto un poquito más hacia la orilla
vaya lo logramos tenemos aquí nuestro
distribuidor de energía este es para
cinco bots por lo que tomamos nuestros
cables de energía de 5 volts y debemos
tener cuidado de cómo los colocamos por
debajo de estos otros cables pareciera
que vamos a hacer un tejido con los
cables para llevar los cables de energía
a donde queremos
muy bien lo logramos pelamos los
extremos unos 6 milímetros más o menos
y listo
colocamos estos cables en donde van en
nuestro circuito provisional para
proporcionar la energía
usamos el destornillador para ayudarnos
a empujar cada cable en su lugar hacemos
lo mismo con el cable positivo
luce bien
parece que todo está bien colocado
ahora podemos dar energía a nuestras
conexiones como la de la cámara que
vamos a conectar aquí y así tendremos
energía de manera que cuando mandemos la
señal para que la cámara se encienda
tendrá la energía para hacerlo como lo
haría con las baterías
nuevamente tenemos más cable del que
necesitamos así que vamos a cortar el
exceso así está bien siempre podemos
ajustar cuando tenemos cable de más pero
no es lo mismo cuando nos quedamos
cortos de cable pelamos los extremos
este es el cable positivo de la batería
y vamos a tratar de pasarlo por debajo
de todo esto con cuidado es casi como si
enhebrar a mos una aguja
ya tenemos energía para encender nuestra
cámara que requiere de 5 volts y lo
podremos usar cuando encendamos nuestra
cámara